let's do this
it's a beautiful night to be alive but
let me ask you something
are you hiring do you know where to post
your job to find the best candidates
no juggling emails or call to your
office quickly screen candidates rate
them and hire the right person and right
now my listeners can post jobs on
ziprecruiter for free by going to
ziprecruiter.com
slash church that's ziprecruiter.com
church
number two
elevate your [ __ ] underwear
game to the next level you understand me
with me undies stop [ __ ] around me
undies are designed in la and made from
micro moldol a fabric three times softer
than cotton and right now today
if you don't want a subscription that's
okay you can still say it because
meundies is offering you 20
off your first pair just use our special
url meundies.com
joey and get 20 percent off your first
pair and this show is all
also brought to you by listen you're
having a hard time sleeping you know why
because you got a dead mattress do me a
favor
go to helixleep.com
answer a few simple questions based on
four preferences and the result will be
a custom sleep profile and right now
today go to helix.com
joey and i'll give you 50
off your first order who's better than
uncle joey that's helixsleep.com slash
joey again helix sleep.com joey that's
who puts this podcast together give him
some heat lisat
there you go
oh [ __ ]
it's a new attitude [ __ ]
there we go
australians coming at you
oh [ __ ] you're lucky i don't smoke dads
this is just on regular reefer and
[ __ ] energy and testosterone straight
from the nut sac the church of what's
happening now [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
tv screen
420 not talking about it not hanging
posters
he's in 2000 milligrams deep
everybody knows about these oh god here
we go
so we're going to get these at your
store and we'll and we'll get you some
promo your phone saying you know how we
do it dog what's happening i'm welcoming
me to the church and what's happening
now my girl jessamy paluso is here i'm
here lisa and what we're doing tonight
listen all these [ __ ] amateurs
they want to celebrate 420 around here
we live it on a daily basis you know i
don't [ __ ] with your people we ain't
doing math
we ain't eating pills we ain't doing
well we ain't doing that we're
struggling every [ __ ] reefer i gave
up edibles for lent
because it got out of hand two thousand
a day you can't live like that that's
that's not a regular human being and it
was 2 000 plus did you really give them
up yeah for lent i went to church
wednesday i got the [ __ ] ashes put on
my head then i went home and i did my
own ceremony in the backyard out of
respect what kind of what was that like
go back there you blow some smoke
and you [ __ ] put the ashes on your
head out of respect for the holy ghost
so it's always the father the son of the
holy ghost the holy ghost is griefing
reefer it's reefer reefers the holy
ghost all these people never 2 000 years
now one of you [ __ ] intelligent
people to figure this out i got left
back in the seventh grade i figured that
out the holy smoke is the holy ghost has
always been
what's a ghost uh some dude who bothers
you oh no it's somebody who [ __ ] gets
you going you don't see what it is it's
invisible yeah it's like smoke the
marijuana yeah when you blow it out your
world changes and i'm not talking here
from a loser perspective i'm telling you
when you blow it out you blow it out and
all your troubles go away even if it's
for an hour and a half they do you
giggle like a [ __ ] [ __ ] you ever
see a [ __ ] game you also want to pull
up the cuckoo's nest it looks so happy
nobody's getting slashed nobody's
getting [ __ ] bombed nobody's getting
cut in the subway yeah it's just
laughter it's just laughter
it's that's all it is
and
a feeling of elation sometimes you're
creative as hell i wish i'd go back to
getting high like when i was 12. like
when i was 12 me and my little buddies
we used to go to lunch at shoprite
right right about put a lunch at shop
right [ __ ] yeah cause we could shop lift
bubba hubba bubba and we [ __ ] go
shoplift a ten pack of hubba bubba i
could listen to you say hubba bubba
listen
repeat we were going there four of us
deep and we would steal 10
44 40 packs of hubba bubba and we get
smart and we get a tube okay like a
glass thing and you put a joint in there
and then you cover it and it was like a
flute and you smoked it okay yeah and
then you you walk back to school
thinking like reefing you get so high
that you sit on the glass tube
how many times i broke that [ __ ] tube
not one time that i got a stitch in my
ass not one because you got a thick ass
and then the cocaine ever came and they
had a thing called double barrel
shotguns where it was a glass with a
scoop at the end and you scooped it into
the bag and went like this and and i
would sit on those too how old were you
oh that's when i was 17. holy [ __ ] i'm
not that seventeen's five it was funny
last week i was a giant
chance dragging in
right down the corner from bananas when
you'll be at bananas get an uber and
don't take it a chance drag it in that's
where it all starts that sounds like
some real chinese [ __ ] [ __ ] i'll show
you the pictures later but when i was 16
used to have a we used to have a driving
coach
north bergen at the time had a driving
coach what does that mean what the
hell's the driving code you're ready for
this is does that involve a horse
because i will die no no no no no okay
i'm thinking like a quarter teacher for
four periods you would sign up when you
got your permit
yeah and he would take you and three
other people on a car ride and you would
switch
and then when you went to get your gym
teacher like a gym teacher i think why
was your gym did you doing that people i
don't
and then the cars came coupe de ville so
there were two of them and on the side
they said north bergen education yeah uh
sponsored by the massachusetts right so
demacia agreed to give the high school
two cadillacs and they put special
pedals in it
for the [ __ ] teacher in case you were
[ __ ] gym teacher to do it the gym
teacher had to be certified yeah he's
like you know i do gym and i also do
driving so they all did like two or
three periods how much
so it was like so there was like three
different teachers that did it but two
of the three teachers were stiffs we had
this teacher called mr mcgrath the camel
mr mcgrath doesn't even sound real we
called him camel breath grab the giraffe
because he called smoke cigarette camel
cigarettes with no filter and his
cigarette his mustache was orange from
the camel cigarettes i can't i'm not
gonna survive listen to me and his
fingers were orange
still to today he won't [ __ ] be my
friend
on facebook till today
every year i go back to that page and i
click on
and he's pissed cause i've told these
stories over here plus i owed his
partner like eight grand and been book
making mr polluted mr pollute died god
forbid god forbid that guy is still
alive when we were freshman mr pollute
was the freshman baseball coach and also
the driving teacher no we abused
we abused the [ __ ] out of pollute for
luke would take the ball
pollute would take the ball and go like
this and hit the ball left field
and he would go left field and then they
would catch the ball all these freshmen
and they would hold the ball and pull it
would go where the [ __ ] are all the
balls and all of a sudden nine people
would whip balls out of the speed of
lightning and one day they knocked them
out poor palu got knocked out
sophomore year we were part of the
gourmet club and mr mcgregor like a chef
club listen to this listen to this
north north berlin high school had a
thing called the gourmet club
and one sunday every month you got
together you rented a bus you paid dues
you had to be a junior and above
a senior and you play dues and mr
mcgrath and three other teachers [ __ ]
would take you into the city to a famous
restaurant and then you'd eat the food
and go back to one of the teacher's
houses so these people so your teachers
would just take you on dates listen to
me there you go in the car your parents
no no it's a restaurant there's a bus a
bus and you had to pay to be part of a
gourmet club right like every school has
[ __ ] [ __ ] organizations the
photography club
the gourmet club the first plumbers club
every high school everybody in this room
was part of some [ __ ] [ __ ]
organization in [ __ ] high school okay
in my high school they had like the
dudes who built the sets and all that
stupidity but
they also had but they also had the
gourmet club and you would meet once a
month in front of high school i'm just
imagining that on the sweatshirt the
dudes are both dead oh my god and all
that stupidity oh yeah all that [ __ ]
that guy's name was bob pullman listen
bob pullman used to get weed scent when
we were in high school from hawaii
on sticks in a little rapper vacuum
sealed in 1979 they were ahead of the
game then 35 hours for [ __ ] three
joints we thought we were getting robbed
that we would put oh my god shipped from
hawaii right this is how crazy you guys
are smoking hibiscus so we go to [ __ ]
we go to [ __ ] uh
we go to chinatown they take you eat
china chinese food
and then you go back to somebody's house
so he got so pathetic i mean the the
gourmet club that that one year they let
the sophomores in and i was a sophomore
and we all got on the bus and went to
some [ __ ] restaurant on the way back
went to pollute house pollute you went
to pollutes houses
she had a beautiful i feel like there's
some boundaries being crossed at the
school i know there'd be a bunch of
teachers there yeah that's a question
it's getting worse so there'd be a bunch
of teachers that asked you stupid
questions about the restaurant and you
had to make believe like it oh the egg
rolls were great you know i've been to a
few places and sometimes the young girls
are salty so listen to me you're part of
the first year my requirement for an egg
roll is saltiness listen to mcdonald's
so we're there maybe an hour we're there
maybe 20 minutes
and we take now all these [ __ ]
students are really on the up and up
they're talking about the oregano and
the clam and the invention of the clam
and me and my goombas look at each other
we're like listen pass the hat around
this is my favorite spice
clams are
oregano and like adding a spice to it
there's clams or regulator okay which is
like uh there's there's bake clams
that's what [ __ ] gentiles eat that
makes me crap my pants i would love to
eat a baked clay right now
at the copper kettle what's that
restaurant where people they give you a
chocolate [ __ ] fountain that sounds
good i always put my finger in there
what's the name of the [ __ ] chocolate
fountain um
golden corrupted corral like golden
corral golden corral once a month
they'll have big clams you go in there
you end up [ __ ] dead you understand
me i don't even know crying out of your
ass oh my god it's a [ __ ] horror show
so don't go to bank around get bait
clams that's what
people people like in [ __ ] montana go
to like uh what's that restaurant uh
what's the italian place where people go
carabas no olive garden olive green oh
the italian place olive garden they go
to olive oil
listen you know that when you go to utah
when you're going to start you ever go
to salt lake city wise yes
that's the best that's the biggest
olive garden in the country for reals i
missed out where that's where the most
action
in the country is that's one of the most
at that olive garden out of our way what
are people doing just fingering each
other in the line [ __ ] breadsticks
just fishing each other i like the salad
i like the endless salad it's the food
that [ __ ] gives you for 10 days
when i was in pittsburgh that's what
would keep me together for three days
pittsburgh's food is pittsburgh's food
is going to sleep on delivery don't [ __ ]
with pittsburgh jack even at the hotel i
got the menu and the egg rolls were
delicious the pork fried rice they don't
[ __ ] around and up the corner was an
olive garden i hit it every day for
lunch like a savage olive garden for
lunch pasta facial soup and the endless
salad and then i would go to the [ __ ]
get the egg roll with the pork fried
rice for dinner like
can you always say pasta fazool the way
you say pasta fazool like makes me pee a
little what the [ __ ] do you think you're
doing
yeah
and just i don't know if you know this
he said he'll show you the pictures from
chan dragon in later it's it's not it's
not like it's not like his friends like
a oh it's like a group picture
he has pictures of his food i don't want
to take pictures of people you take
pictures of your food when i go to the
channel
but do you like you put filters in it
you take pride in the photo no just to
remember like [ __ ] felix what do you
do jerk off to it later no he takes
pride in the show he shows everybody to
show these [ __ ] maggots
what the [ __ ] you know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about i can show him
you'll send me a photo what i should eat
and i'll show him you come to me and go
send i went to this place in santa
monica by the beach i go rudy's spicy
muffins like a [ __ ] yeah
since i was 16 i've been going there
with a heineken on tap
yankee pot roast for the chorizo in the
middle are you [ __ ] kidding me
in life no parole
the [ __ ] jew bakery look look at the
jew bakery a [ __ ] a [ __ ]
strawberry shortcake who takes a pen i
didn't eat it i just take a picture and
show these out
look at this look at the chinese food
this is going to be down the corner from
where you got bananas
you see the metal you don't see metal in
this country no more these fools don't
know nothing about metal look at those
[ __ ] egg rolls you're gonna come to
me i used to weigh 418 pounds and it was
solid muscle why because i ate the best
i didn't [ __ ] around look at this look
at those spare ribs look at that they've
been there since i was [ __ ] 16 and my
point is
mr mcgrath camel breath
used to [ __ ] we'd get in the car and
we'd have to go up to the ridgefield
circle and make a u-turn and somebody
else would drive
so we would go mcgrath while we're here
let's just get some egg rolls a chance
and here we go are you [ __ ] kidding
me i'm gonna die so we started at first
it was egg rolls come on mr mcgrath
let's get some egg rolls and cheers i'll
buy it would you call it in the head
what's that called egg rolls ahead
no no in those days there was no cell
phones we didn't know no numbers he just
showed up and said let me get [ __ ]
let me get that what have you got eight
egg rolls
and then the egg roll thing went on for
like a month
every day we had the
11 15 slot eleven fifteen twelve o'clock
that was it you had to sign up on a
piece of paper it was all legit this was
all legit so when you got there in
school right away the night before i
would call pollution the pollution
you got first class uh shop tomorrow
first class is 7 30. right first period
yeah yeah yeah when you're stupid and
young you're like i'll go to fourth
period at 9 50. yeah you're a [ __ ] go
at 7 30 or either one you [ __ ] reach
out
so you're going to be there early do me
a favor when you go sign in for
for me for me right because i'm going to
go get a salty egg roll my boy
no we're just going to go hang out yeah
it started with egg rolls nobody gets
steak on a stick and then we get steak
on a stick and then we talk them into a
liquor store mcgrath we gotta go to all
like this what started with egg roll
needs to be
your movie listen to me
it started with that girl and after
about three or four weeks we started
getting the mcgrath
pull over let's get a six pack are you
guys crazy i'm losing my life nobody's
gonna know we would get an eight pack
eight pack that's when there was eight
packs that night eight oh yeah yeah like
ov splits yeah
eight ounces yeah
and we would drink the eight pack in 45
minutes before we get and he would he
would just sit there and nod his head
there was nothing he could do we had him
by the balls by the end of my junior
year i had mcgregor taking me to [ __ ]
west new york
like i would tell him i was going to go
get something he and i both knew what
did you he knew what the real deal was
he knew i would say give me a man i
gotta go see my step-back i gotta pick
up a hundred dollars
but he knew i was going to west new york
yeah pick up something and he always
played it off
it was until the day right after i
didn't graduate high school
because i quit my senior year then i
went back and i had short credits so i
said i'm not even going to bother some
school i'm not blowing my summit i got a
diploma i got a diploma later
so the day after i was supposed to
graduate was the first time you said
come to my house because
we robbed this drug dealer and i gave it
and i called them up which class was
that for this was no class this was just
a [ __ ] uh this was just an
extracurricular activity this was just
us on the friday night we
we go listen bro let's go get coke the
guy goes he's in the city
perfect let's go rob him
if he's in the city he ain't never gonna
come back to jersey we were crazy dog i
tell you i was one of those savages
you're a legit savage crazy this is just
this is great like most kids go to
school and get that dick sucked by the
high school teachers and [ __ ]
that sounds amazing this was completely
different most kids like you know
today's kids they [ __ ] get their
dicks like when they go home to the
psychotherapist how many kids are
getting their dick socks by their
teachers a lot these days it's so tough
i want to get i got to get hypnotized
for my fear but the biggest problem
happened last week i went to get
hypnotized now she's a good looking
woman chick who hypnotizes me is a great
like she's a great hypnotist i wonder if
that's a factor in it
she sells it but she's really attractive
and i know she's married so last week i
went in there
and i just said to her does your husband
work in the business and she goes no to
be honest and my husband is a she so she
so she couldn't really hypnotize me
because i kept thinking about [ __ ]
her eating dance
and stuff you're not into like girl on
girl stuff that doesn't do anything for
you it doesn't matter whether i'm into
it and i'm just saying that it was tough
for her to hypnotize yeah because she
dropped that bomb on me yeah you know
next thing you know i'm having fun
yeah you're thinking about it i'm coming
on her feet not a [ __ ] hypnotic watch
that little hypnotic watch i'm [ __ ]
on it like a [ __ ] savage watch so
last week she couldn't really get deep
into hypnotizing me so i had to tell it
i said listen you can't do drop that
bomb on me an hour before you're going
to put me out yeah wait till after yeah
wait till after you have all these wet
dreams digest that let me digest it on
the planes for six hours or something
before you [ __ ] look down yeah next
time tell me slower and in my ear it's
crazy what goes in my mind and how it
affects us how long have you been
hypnotized for about four weeks how are
you liking it
i'm getting somewhere yeah yeah i'm
getting somewhere and afterwards do you
feel like it's a sort of thing where you
feel cleansed after or something like
you know after you have like a good high
you feel like you've figured out some
problems let me tell you something man
this works like a double this has worked
out for me like uh
i never really got beside when i was in
the halfway house
and they made me call it order [ __ ]
some therapist i never went to a
therapist i didn't see the value yeah in
fact i called my prison therapist
about a month ago his name was hobby
schweiber i just came up with his name
one night after 30 years ago that was
his name
wow i looked him up on youtube on the on
google and i found him and the next day
i called him he was happy to hear from
me he told me where the whole staff of
all the halfway houses were where all
the my old counselors were at
so that was the only therapy i had ever
taken
and this is sort of like half therapy
half hypnotism right because she talks
to me about what's going on
you know what's bothering you
and then we go over a technique she'll
put on like some music
do you legit like can
do you legit get hypnotized like
yeah
are you conscious when you're hypnotized
are you like out i [ __ ] hear
different [ __ ] you do yeah like this
what like mouse farts no like let me
play it for you and [ __ ]
because my dad got hypnotized a while
back but to quit smoking it didn't work
it didn't work welcome to mind magic
tapes
this is a self-hypnosis trainer
you
will be talked through training
on noticing the symptoms of
self-hypnosis
hypnosis will be i feel like it's going
to hypnotize me and i'm going to [ __ ] on
your
you will tend to have your jaw relax and
your teeth part slightly during this
particular i'm clenching my teeth right
now
when your eyes are closed and going
through this exercise
you will find that your eyelids become
heavy and stuck tight they should use
cosby's voice
[Laughter]
that's hilarious you will begin to
notice
an increase in saliva flow as your body
relaxes that's not saliva hypnotize
there's something that's putting this
jizz in your mouth we're both sick in
the head meanwhile you're like what the
[ __ ] we're like we don't need therapy
it's just an automobile
or at any time you are not in a secure
and safe place where you will not be
disturbed
an overview of this process i can't
imagine you hypnotized
is to enable you
to recognize
the symptoms of self-hypnosis
i don't
to begin to suggest to yourself but if
you hypnotize yourself example
suggestions will be given what happens
like you notice you go into a [ __ ]
frame suggestion like are you just
chilling in the in the ether suggestions
yeah you're just chilling suspended yeah
so let's begin
oh my goodness oh you hear stuff
in a comfortable position
close your eyes
and roll the eyeballs comfortably upward
jesus christ this is freaky this is what
you need to do people we're going to be
scared of needles
you're going to do this to give blood
yeah because i get scared of knees you
do
what if a girl in the cute little outfit
did it instead would that help you
i don't even think about it no and
letting it out slowly
you of all people are scared of needles
yeah that's why i go to acupuncture so i
overcome that fear is it working yeah
yeah but i still get like the
blood out i still get
i get sometimes but not as bad anymore
and imagine doubling i just imagine it's
a teeny dick going into my skin each
number you count to yourself
imagine each number is though it's
drifting out of your mind i mean this
[ __ ] is freaky no thank you all right
let's get out right yeah yeah i'm in the
second place right now
at the second place
now watch the number address
this sounds like like it's something
they play at a cult meeting yeah joe's
going to turn me into a banker yeah
because he can't beat you
listen i'm scared it's gonna work
in your imagination
and she is so freaky
feel calm stop looking at me like that
joey
you [ __ ] don't know what you're
missing this [ __ ] that see if i listen
to that i'd be i'd be too scared to
listen to that alone this is why and
there's some dude in an echoey voice who
is that guy i don't even know him what's
he look like
marvin i don't give a [ __ ] i don't ask
questions he tells me what i need to do
when i do it
as long as he don't touch me you don't
want no money i'm fine you know what i'm
saying that once he started borrowing
that's like i throw my hotel room that
[ __ ] helps you fall asleep
i had a heart i had a [ __ ] up week
last week like last monday night i
couldn't sleep
and tuesday i had to sleep i i i should
have got six or seven hours i slept like
three hours and i had to get picked up
at 4 30 to go to new york
then i got to new york and i went to eat
with my friends chinese food
you know i still go loyalty 35 years
later i still that's the first
restaurant i go to when i get off the
plane
and then i went back to the room
couldn't fall asleep that's the worst i
don't be an anthony they told me coming
at nine
to close out this show that was no big
deal
i woke up at three in the morning oh my
lord and couldn't fall back and then i
by the time one o'clock came i was dizzy
well guess what i get to knock at 1 30.
you think i could fall asleep
no she must have been reeling i could
feel my blood pressure rising from the
no sleep yep
i get to the club and it was a [ __ ]
nightmare i had to go upstairs i told
matt fultron to follow me up
because i was getting the anxiety in the
green room i couldn't breathe
you thought you're gonna pass out yes i
went and sent him to cvs he was so great
and i gave him
he brought back like some baby medicine
to just
thin me out a little bit and i went and
did the [ __ ] hour and i went home and
that night i slept like a [ __ ] baby
what was the baby medicine like crack
what's that no it just it was uh a heart
medication i just needed my blood
pressure to go yeah to relax
so i went to the hotel room that night
10 o'clock
10 30 i got my pajamas on again you
couldn't fall asleep see i would have
passed the [ __ ] out right there i'm
[ __ ] furious at this point i get so
angry when i can't sleep ready just to
go to the hospital and give me demerol
let me sleep at the hospital from uh
exhaustion yeah
and i said wait a second let me put
those earphones on with that thing
with that creepy guy the creeper guy put
you to
went to bed at sleep i fell asleep
and i think i woke up at [ __ ] 7 30
quarter eight
i took two hits in a vapor pen a cup of
coffee ran downstairs got coffee i got
took a [ __ ] no i got those uh soft eggs
with two pieces of white bread and some
oatmeal now you got me hungry and i went
right back upstairs and fell right back
to sleep for another four [ __ ] hours
that's good i was tiptop too but that
[ __ ] tape
help me relax the first night because my
heart was beating you know my heart my
mind was running away with me my heart
was beating you ever yank the weasel to
make you fall asleep
at this point in the game it's just
an unnecessary mess right yeah oh my god
an unnecessary mess his second movie
titled 54 years old
what do you mean you still don't yank it
no i i'll yank it i don't give a [ __ ]
but i'm saying sometimes you say let me
yank and you're gonna
what if you i'll wait till i take a
shower or whatever then the shower
didn't work good i just heard if you
yank it makes you fall asleep
yeah yeah
you just turn over so you do it
especially in the hotel
the side of the bed oh geez now we know
how you do it
yeah that's good or a guy that goes just
man i don't want to [ __ ] you just let me
eat your [ __ ] yeah fall asleep
that's a pacifier it's a pacifier yeah
once you shoot a [ __ ] good old load a
nice old load you get an old load that
mixed with a new low yeah and it
torments you but you don't know what's
happening yeah it's like and dust and
fresh chicken but now i want roast beef
that type of [ __ ] even saying like i
ordered chicken but i meant roast beef
that type of [ __ ] when you're
self-tormented in 1985 i didn't get a
piece of [ __ ] for nine months
i was walking around like a [ __ ] time
i didn't know what was going on i
couldn't get arrested i couldn't do it
nothing
it was the cold spell from my december
of 84
till june of 85. i didn't see a boob not
a tit
and i wasn't doing drugs see i cleaned
up the coke
so i couldn't see when you're an ugly
dude as long as you've got a big coke
rock oh you got a little piece of monkey
but oh my god i got up and i lost my
game because that was the close to come
back to the room and let's do a couple
of bumps that was the closer
that was a deal sealer yeah once you do
three or four lines you're gonna do the
whole eight ball and at that time it's
eight in the morning you're crying by
your boyfriend but you'll suck the horn
it don't matter you at least suck my
dick you know what i'm saying don't tell
nobody i'm who am i gonna tell i'm i'm
[ __ ]
i'm an fbi agent i don't say nothing i'm
noticed
it was all it was always percentages
ugly dudes just gotta play a game of
percentages yeah but if i could lure you
to the nest it was fifty percent that i
was gonna get you if you snore the coke
i could bet by like four you i'll have
you licking my nut sack by eight third
it was crazy see cosby did the same
thing but it was he would drug them i
wouldn't drug them
and that they weren't voluntarily i'm
saying like he did it but forced him and
made him yeah he went there with false
impressions he said we got him a job
right right next thing you were like the
nice guy route yeah
everybody enjoys cocaine the friendly
coke guy the friendly code guy hi come
on it was like opposite of cosplay it
was a stat and it's just from coke and
let them cry about their boyfriend let
me tell you something
i can't tell you how many times women
will come over
and look me straight in the face and go
before i come over i just want to tell
you nothing's going to happen i'm
happily married
and by the end of the night i was
choking on your horn and i would play
the game like are you [ __ ] kidding me
i just want to smoke coke with somebody
i'm calling my girlfriend that's fine
you don't know how many times they call
their girlfriends and by the end of the
night they both beat each other's [ __ ]
it was crazy and i wouldn't be getting
invited i would just sit there and go
check off on our chats don't touch this
fat man i don't give a [ __ ] i drink off
on that tit by the end of like one of
them would lick my nuts it was crazy i
don't give a [ __ ] i can't tell you how
many nights a woman looked me in the
face and said i'll do cocaine with you
but don't even think about it i love my
man
i've been with him that's the woman's
way though
i wouldn't even say nothing
they'd go in the bathroom to pee and
then come out and say have i ever showed
you my tits i just got them ready and
i'd sit down no no not really and that
would drive a woman crazy
oh yeah
if you don't pay the attention can i
show them to you no no no i don't want
to see them yep
they will show them to you they come in
the bathroom and they come out ball's
ass naked and they tell me about how
they got a tattoo or hitler on their
[ __ ] and why they went to a [ __ ]
german family reunion you know they
don't give a [ __ ] they will throw
themselves killer on the [ __ ] huh bro i
was at work like on the list it's
hysterical
at that point at five in the morning
people would just
tell you their whole life like i really
like anal but i don't like when the dick
is too and you're looking at them going
i just want to get a dick suck and
they're like i'll do anal but i don't
know i like it really big but not really
are you reading for my diary no they'll
tell you all this [ __ ] about
i had a girl tell me once i love when
you guys come fast i go then you're
gonna love me
then you got the right you hit the
jackpot tonight
she goes i've never liked the guy that
go over like three minutes it bothers me
i like it real fast and sweet that's
what turned me on really and they just
come they would just come clean on their
own
there was no twisting their arm it was
[ __ ] crazy it was amazing i've sat
with lee
one night on the corner here oh my god
just like it just came out of me like
all those
road stories yeah that now i look back
at them and i just
like as a road comic like a filthy male
but male road comics are filthy filthy
because you guys clean up
house afterwards what do you mean after
you want to get off stage a funny dude
that's so attractive to women but no no
no no it wasn't even that time no it was
a weird disgusting world
back then
yeah well the air it was a different era
it was a feature act yeah all right so
that's the best job in common it is
20 minutes i get off stage and i hang
out creepy by the women's bathroom
oh you were funny really
the next thing you know they're
swallowing the sword
you were funny you don't know how many
ladies and i'll pass over
swallowing the sword suck my sword
memoir title suck my sword on a tuesday
and then come back to the show on friday
with their husband introduce me to their
husbands follow-up title just crazy [ __ ]
that
it's really crazy out there to digest
it's disgusting it's despicable
what just
savage is savage active savagery
yeah
i think i see i disagree i don't think
that's savage i've always been approved
like i'll go home the next morning go
what the [ __ ]
happened last night like well i gotta go
i gotta talk to somebody a priest
like that type of craziness i think a
prude means that you don't do it i think
you do it and maybe feel a little
remorse oh please i really feel you got
that guilt oh
disgusting how are you raised catholic
like a mother yeah that's right
don't think about a girl that was
married happily married
i saw her at the park with her kids and
one night i played it in pink pong for a
blue job and [ __ ]
i went to this party and then she was
playing ping-pong beating everybody
i i
waited i waited like a [ __ ] possum
and i got there and i ping-ponged her
out and she's telling me she likes to
suck dick well let's play the ping pong
what are you talking about
i can't i can't even handle you sing
ping pong that is crazy i legit can't
handle it
like what is this lady thinking today
does she not remember she lost to
somebody in ping pong and her suckers
wait who brought up the bet please tell
me it was you like the the thing it must
have been someone must have said yeah
who brought the bed up that's a good
question like
it had to be you that was like all right
if you win
no no no
she was playing ping pong and then she
started talking about something sucking
and digging like listen
that's in the comments
right it's five in the morning we're
both cooked up [ __ ] it you lose you suck
my dick
she won what'd she get
finger your butt i think i gave her
grandma coke or something like that
and i know i wasn't going to give it
again because if i watched that
meanwhile she doesn't know that's a
nickname for your dick listen i want to
hit it with the [ __ ] car you don't
meet dogs he comes chasing me and my
coke i'm back into that [ __ ] in boulder
they'll blame another [ __ ] raccoon i
don't give a [ __ ] jack how seriously did
you take that game of ping pong did we
like smile
were you like force gump i was playing
to the death you understand me
up and everything they [ __ ] people's up
in making bottle caps no they did
chinese people get ping pong they
[ __ ] like a [ __ ] that's
because it's their name as well no no
it's [ __ ] craziness to this day i
think about what's that woman thinking
she's got to be 50 like me
and she's gotta say i lost a game of
ping pong one time
and sucked the chubby dude's dick who
was like a half-assed comedian at the
time
living in his friend's basement
disgusting i think she probably blocks
that out i don't think do people have
like think about that what if what if
what happens is every time she plays
ping pong she ends up sucking dick
can you imagine that can you you gave
her like yeah
she's like i don't know i can't i don't
know what it is but i can't
i i
swallow a sword i used to have a
roommate manny who's a creepy guy he was
older than me
he's about 70 now whenever i go home
sometimes he meets me i give him a bag
of stars
he's a good dude he's a really good dude
he when i was when i did when i went
first went to do time i was 28
man they had to be about 44
42
and manny would get barrels of blow
delivered to the house and even hide
them in paint cans
and he had a really weird friend a
circle of friends
he had all those girls that are crazy
and get naked when they do blow and he
was like a cab driver
one's name was bubbles i'll never forget
that bubbles would suck your dick at
four in the morning if you bumped into
bubbles in the house what else is
bubbles gonna do i know her name is
bubbles she's not solving science
problems i lived at this guy but i would
i would call him at night he used to
drive a cab so i would call the cab
company and go have manny call me at the
house the kitchen's on fire
and he would call me right away and i go
where yeah and he would go i'm getting
off work but i'm going to bubbles this
house she's having a party
she's having to take something so let's
say it was like 11 o'clock
i would go upstairs and do a couple
bumps and take a shower or
listen to music and maybe go out to the
balcony nobody was going to be home
unless he didn't have coke with him then
he'd have to come home and get a batch
to take back but besides that it was
just me and him and judge mudge
and there was a dude his name was greg
munge
judge mike it was a three-bedroom house
greg mudge was a dude that was like a
carpet salesman but his grandfather like
they controlled the whole city near st
louis like the carpet industry no
the law industry someone's great
grandfather was judge mudge over a legit
judge this guy used to get coked up and
bring portraits of his grandfather like
in 1980. this is the original original
judgement oh god this is judge in 1920
it was crazy
so judge mudge had a girlfriend he would
go to his girlfriend's house in the
weekend do blow and get freaky and [ __ ]
so it would just be me in the house so i
would time it and manny told me he was
going to be at jesus house
i would stay upstairs don't wait too
jerk off watch usa night flight that's
an old school show yeah and then about 3
30 i'd take my car but when all those
chicks were wounded [ __ ] seals
all of them were wounded
i'd walking like king farook i was 20
and filled with calm you understand me
and everybody was getting yum yums i
never walk in they're like where are you
coming from and i'd make believe i came
from like
i was at a party with actresses i was at
home jerking off like a [ __ ] moulage
i was out with [ __ ] nobody and i'd
walk in there they'd be wounded there
yeah and i'd pick up the remains the
carcasses that were just laying there
with their mouth open fish on the back
of my shirt it was horrible but every
time i went i'd made a new chick
i'd listen to samia beating
and i ended up giving her a stand here
oh no they give me some me a b how they
were an artist and
they were gonna get a booth at the
farmer's market
you know i need this [ __ ] that's great
you know yeah i harvest honey that's
great you're going to starve that that
for the rest of your life just suck the
pipes i get home and got your [ __ ] to do
at what point do you call off the ear
beating like after like 20 minutes
listen there's no woman that's going to
suck your pipe without giving you a
little bit of an air b well we feel you
got to earn yeah you got to earn it so
you got to take that here beat and make
believe you're interested
yeah no [ __ ] wow how did you get that
yeah but what what
what if you're there for an hour are you
still talking to her no after the 40
minute march she's got to take her shirt
off
she's got to take her shoes off for some
science
yes collateral's got to start happening
it's a little warm in here right now
take that shirt off have you seen my new
bra oh my god i shouldn't be showing you
i'm engaged you know the whole [ __ ]
thing it cost me 34 hours of victoria's
secret let me see
yeah no [ __ ] does it come with matching
underwear yeah but i can't show you
those it's come on i'll leave my finger
i'm saying
do another blast i'll show you the
fiance okay but you won't tell nobody
the next thing you know they take them
all and the pants come off and they're
snorting a bikini and you're like what
the [ __ ] i do deserve this
and then you start and then you just
know how to do it oh no then it's like a
slow finger yeah it's like every 15
minutes you're talking about the story
you put on some music
you throw them off you put a little
music on they think it's like seriously
you know what
it's as much as from your perspective oh
yeah you know you know what time it was
yeah girls that go into it knowing that
they don't they came everyone likes the
dance the dance everyone put a little
music on
they dance next we like to be like oh we
don't want it and you know
i don't mean to disrespect you but you
really really have some nice press
really you think so
oh i thought you were telling me i was
like thank you and i realized it was a
story
they'll tell you they'll say let me uh
let me uh i can't tell you you like my
system we got no coke
[Laughter]
real problem yeah have we had clothes
my sister forget about it i love that
hearing in your nose oh my god
what no i just didn't matter
it's such a strong feminine figure thank
you
it's such a strong feminine figure of
independence oh my god i can't believe
you see that as a man it means so much
you recognize that most men from the
east coast don't really see that you're
so sensitive do you want one of your
balls in my mouth or both oh boy and
then you start telling them how your
mother died i found her in the kitchen i
loved my mother but once you start
talking about your mother it's all over
it's done you gotta get them before they
start talking about the mom
don't come in my mouth listen my mother
raised a gentleman i would never come in
your mouth bam come in your butthole
yeah no you come everywhere you you they
always tell you don't come in my mouth
that means
my throat is open you know what i'm
saying when they tell you don't come in
my mouth that means my throat is open up
next on more casualties this is
definitely the episode that gets kicked
off of itunes
no once they tell you don't come in my
mouth that means don't shoot that
[ __ ] bell you know that little bell
they have in the back of their throat
that's the target if you hit the bell
you get a little doll i can call it over
you get 10 tickets
[Music]
it's that type of knife [ __ ]
uncle joey coming at you live
my girl jessame paluso and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
at least
2 000 milligrams deep of the stars of
death look at them how you feeling
you're going through changes two nights
in a row dog you're a [ __ ] marine you
understand me yeah it's pretty bad it's
but here we go no no i'm sorry i even
asked you he's gonna start stuttering no
it didn't happen
i don't want to speak badly that just
because people passed away but this week
there have been two
food uh
like the the challenges where you have
to eat a lot of food and that people
have died from yeah
pancake challenge pancake and donut oh
good but those are both like doughy
things like you can't i can't even i
almost died on a pancake at brunch last
week i wasn't even trying to do a
challenge jesus that was just people
died in threes and you wanted to go to
buffet and lawful
people die in three and this one wants
to do something well he was in law firm
last week i'm going to try to get the
egg challenge did you do an egg
challenge
you would do another one strangled him
on the phone he was gonna eat chinese
food at the grand canyon like any
chinese people stayed behind there's a
[ __ ] people in disguise with
halloween's costumes you're better off
eating sticks from the dirt thank god
thank god that's what i got to deal with
you know
but anyway what else is going on with
you oh you know i'm just living life i
invested in dispensaries so that's
opening up in like a month what is the
grand opening uh well the grand
opening's gonna be a little bit later
we're gonna have all our friends i'm
gonna invite you to come by smoke some
dough no
are you gonna be working it two a couple
days a week uh if they need me to yeah
but i'll be on i'll be on like the other
side for for sure
we're gonna do a podcast from there we
have like a little lounge area that
we're gonna do a podcast from
very smart yeah we're excited we have a
nice little backyard with chickens in it
and [ __ ]
probably chicken [ __ ] as well
it's called laflora organica gonna be
opening probably in like a month or so
are they guard chickens yeah they are
guard chickens guard [ __ ] if you will
we put like uh
spike collars around their necks and we
train them to peck people right in their
dicks what made you want to open up the
dispensary well i've been working with
honey bear farms for a while like i met
them
uh probably like over a year ago and we
just were friends hanging out and then
one day
they asked if i wanted to be a partner
and i was like [ __ ] yeah i wanna you
know you gotta diversify and stretch out
and
take risks diversify diversify like tony
montana yeah before you [ __ ] yeah
so we just uh it just worked out it was
just like you know synergistic how it
all came from
thank you making the movie yeah
making them i saw you one
high court wasn't it fun it was fun it
was fun i was fine blasted people were
because i only took like on the show it
only looked like i took one hit from the
from the bong
but they don't realize like in the green
room everyone's [ __ ] around we're all
smoking no i saved myself for the
[ __ ] show i saved myself like yeah i
didn't [ __ ] around
you know i was getting anxiety sitting
there smoking yeah that's what i was
like i was really yeah
it was terrible my throat was hurting
yeah
i got dry mouth yeah yeah it was [ __ ]
weird i i was blasted i started dancing
in the back it's amazing that doug got
that show on the that's your choice to
show you
crazy
it's crazy it's 2017. it's a 2 000
[ __ ]
on the air that they smoke dope they
smoke dope and it's called the high
court it's not even like an innuendo for
15
and even though the dea says it's
illegal and the whole thing
it don't get like the show is on the
[ __ ] it's on the air and the fact
that even marijuana like that we're in
this
scenario is so crazy like look at what
alcohol has done to people for years and
will continue to do to people how many
people die with alcohol related deaths
it's it is like an epidemic well i said
on the podcast last night or i sat on
the periscope that i read somewhere
that all the wheat all the states that
have medical marijuana something like
that
emergency opioid
things are down
and i always said that i always said you
know what man
it's a transfer of addiction but i'd
much rather you smoke dope [ __ ] yeah
over opiates uh oxycontin yeah people
are dying left and right that's a
epidemic right now for sure so look at
the
oh in ohio the heroin problem i mean you
know i don't know how many people are
dying daily
and it's so weird the logic behind it
you go away for 30 days for a rehab
right and they put you on other drugs no
you come out of that rehab and you go to
shoot what you were shooting before you
went to that rehab it's like if i come
down
like i'm allowed to eat edibles on
easter sunday that's when the egg is
going to hatch that's when jesus comes
out of the hole
that's when i eat a [ __ ] edible
so what i'm going to do is
if you think i'm going to eat 2 000
edibles right off the bat i will have a
heart attack my heart of course won't go
that it won't and that's what really
happened to me last week in that green
room
i brought some weed back with me
that was so [ __ ] strong to the high
court no to where the [ __ ] niagara
classic oh niacc
and i had dry i put all my weed in the
dryer is this when you were tired too
yes see that is those two combined it
was [ __ ] up yeah
i put it in the bag in front of a heater
yep and i said my wife comes and tapes
the bottom down she's like no more i can
smell the weed all over the house and i
granulate that [ __ ] and i smoke it in
bungs or in pipes yeah the road i roll
it
but on the road i'll cut it with a
scissor and put it in there in chunks
yep and i will oh no i get [ __ ] yeah
i got so lit in that green room my heart
was beating up and you were exhausted
already i was wondering you just weren't
your your all your levels were just
discombobulated you were all mixed up so
after this flight this week next
thursday i gotta go ahead and
acupuncture
i've never done that well maybe i had
acupuncture wednesday i'll be on this on
the [ __ ] west side because that
decombinates me back yeah because i've
been going for 10 years
so now it's very easy for her to align
things you've been going action
acupuncture since before i started it's
going to be 10 years this november i
haven't snorted coke and i went to her a
year before i got off the blow so it'll
be 11 years i've been dealing with
that's impressive
bro i'm the type of new loyalty when
somebody does a good job and they treat
me right that's why i still go to chance
that's why i still go to rudy's yeah i
don't disrespect them i won't eat
no other chinese food to disrespect
right you know when i was a kid it was
rudy's or [ __ ] the other one i forget
and for years people would [ __ ] argue
about it i didn't give a [ __ ] i didn't
give a [ __ ] of 18 year old girls hung
out at the other place i went to rudy's
i'm one of those dudes man i don't give
a [ __ ] when the food's good
and you take care of me i'll keep coming
back yeah that's the way it should be
yeah i think so
but
acupuncture makes you relaxed
that night i'll sleep like a baby
i want to try it yeah it's interesting
stuff when i do the cupping to move your
blood around i do the whole [ __ ]
thing man does that hurt is that the cup
the ones that you have welts on your
back yeah does that hurt no
the one there's some points and when she
pulls them off you feel it off your nut
no off your back but you don't uh
you don't really know you get used to
them you know i gotta try that i went
somewhere and i had pulled the forum
i was [ __ ] around
doing something with kettlebells and i
[ __ ] up and i went to do radio
somewhere and they were gonna have a
team there that works on the nfl team it
was charlotte
and the guy came in he goes let me show
you how we do with this they cup you
and then they move it around to loosen
them up it was [ __ ] brilliant like
what they do with that stuff so they use
heat to like
to make the pressure the cup is like me
squeezing you it it's it's like it's in
spanish
come here give me your arm
it's it that's what i'm doing
because you're getting you're like
tomorrow morning you'll wake up and go
joey [ __ ] bruised my arm what they do
is they and then i just start sucking
that suction
gets
like little things that gets your blood
circulating that makes sense like when i
went to dr amy i was probably
at that point maybe 370
and my ankles were swollen she goes
that's the first thing we're going to
work on because that's all basically
acupuncture is about it's circulation
yeah and keeping all the listen nobody
smokes more cigarettes than the chinese
but they have less cancer than we do
when you drive and you see someone doing
in the park
that dude smokes more like a chimney the
tai chi
gets oxygen to all parts of your body
yeah that creates cancer when you don't
give up
a part of your body oxygen yep that's
right so it's really interesting like
all these little things that
listen you have insurance use it i mean
some americans don't have dick and that
breaks my [ __ ] heart i know if a lot
of people don't but a lot of people join
unions or grandfather then you know
and there's so many little things in
your insurance that you're eligible for
like you can get gym memberships like if
you get
a chiropractor once a month yep that
means they'll approve acupuncture once a
month
i gotta look into my insurance man once
you have screen actors gail no i go
through uh blue shield
i was gonna do is this is screen actors
guild one good it's good but you gotta
earn every year yeah see that's the
thing you gotta earn every year which is
that what's good now yeah goal now you
know i gotta earn 33 grand yeah well
mama don't can't get her [ __ ] we'll
look that yeah the doctor you're saying
there's no [ __ ] stirrups yeah they
sent me the form but i already had all
their insurance i just kept it because
you'll have that insurance and once
you're in
for 10 or 15 years
you have insurance for life like i'm old
time it in now for you too i got
everything exciting oh [ __ ] you're
rolling at level two yeah oh [ __ ] i win
you got that gold card the gold card
that means that means i can't go to a
rehab and i can't get glasses
that's it i can still go for my dental
i love that we're like oh you got that
gold card that means i just can't get
levels
level one by now you're probably gonna
make 40 grand a year yeah and that gets
you a rehab uh mental health
and something glasses i think
but you're still paying three bills for
glasses i'm a drunk with bipolar
disorder and i'm blind yeah they still
bring you out for glasses like all that
[ __ ] you got like 30 hours off in
classes you know like that that's just
[ __ ] every time i go for glasses you
drop four hundred dollars that's [ __ ]
i've never it's [ __ ] i don't need
glasses man everyone's gonna hit wait do
you have 42.
especially now the age is gonna go down
because of computers
you think that you think computers are
making us more blind i think that if if
as a natural adult
what what age i started losing my sight
at maybe 44.
now i'm going to tell you something i
can see a red light from eight miles
away
i was one of those dudes when i was
snorting blow you couldn't get anything
past me i could see through a [ __ ]
wall my i always had twenty twenty eight
miles like a straight eight miles or
like a hilly one i go to the
yeah it's curvy i'd be real impressed
when i was a kid i go to the eye doctor
and cry for him to give me glasses and
he's like you got 20 20 vision be happy
i'm like i need glasses
i'm telling you no you don't
and so i always had 20 20 vision when
you turn about 44
[ __ ] starts [ __ ] with you you're like
wait oh man
and then you it really starts going like
it really like if you leave the house
without glasses you're [ __ ] so what
you do is
you go to the doctor
and you get one pair of glasses but you
sit on them and you [ __ ] them up like i
almost sat in your glasses earlier 300
and then you go for a second pan now
they're 350 and one day you go on the tj
maxx and they sell a whole package of 10
for 42 yeah they do because it doesn't
matter you're just gonna break them yeah
[ __ ] it i stepped on mine in the hotel
room last week
looking for him i stepped back i looked
down
i [ __ ] leave i got them in the
[ __ ]
i got a pair in my car and a pair in the
trunk just in case you have a parent in
the bathroom you have to yeah because
sometimes you go in the bathroom you got
your phone in your pocket
and all of a sudden you want to check
your tweets yeah you got some time 20
minutes yeah and all of a sudden you
don't have your glasses do you take
20-minute shits no no no who the [ __ ]
knows how long how long do you think
you're taking it i'm a fast guy i'm too
i'm in and out today i sneezed at the
hype i have the psychotherapist and a
little fart came out i had to run fight
for my car and open up the door
and she still took a whiff of it i felt
so bad
one time when i weighed 400 pounds i
went to dr waxler and i was laying in
the bed and they gave me one of those
hard things and they said you could get
up now and the doctor went to pull me
and as i got up a fart slipped out of my
ass and everybody looked at each other
and i stood in front of the door so
nobody could get out and i'm asking them
stupid questions so how long does this
headache last like well we don't know
let's get the chart before you leave
let me ask you another question
this podcast is brought to you by helix
sleep night after night two people
laying in the same bed but when it comes
time to buy a new mattress only one gets
their way until now
introducing helix sleep where you can
buy mattresses online
customized for both of you for hundreds
of dollars instead of thousands go to
helixsleep.com you answer a few
questions right based on four key
preferences and the result will be a
custom sleep profile used to build you
the most comfortable mattress you'll
ever ever sleep on your mattress will
arrive at your door in about a week and
shipping 100 free and for couples
healers customizes each side of the
mattress personalized to suit each of
your bodies and the way you both flee
helix customers report a 30 improvement
in overall sleep quality you have 100
nights to try it out and if you don't
love it they'll pick it up for a free
and give 100 refund no questions asked
that's why everyone from gq to forbes
are talking about helix sleep do me a
favor this is a mother's day present
this is a father's day present go to
helixleep.com
joey and get 50 off your order all right
that's helixsleep.com
joey and get 50 off your order again
sleep.com
joey let me give some shout outs my man
louis vela bobby sharon joshua jacob
ricky ravioli are you kidding me or what
chris hellbell jacob lee bowden matt
mavin
sam saccoli and savage
cold i don't know what the [ __ ] your
name is this is you or me who the [ __ ]
phone is not me
don't make me strangle mine's off
yeah
these are these people
that should shout out
people hitting you up
no no no they're not gonna need me
thursday night so
i'll be on that [ __ ] plane with joe
joe rogan that's right
buffalo new york i mean the first thing
i'm gonna do is get a beef on wick i
think thursday night if i get it in time
i'm gonna go see steve reynolds easy and
helium dude that's a great club [ __ ]
yeah they need a [ __ ] beef on wick
there's a bunch of things i stay out of
at night you understand draw bridge bars
yeah i don't go nowhere at night i'm an
old man yeah
i'm still a night creeper i like to get
up in those dark corners [ __ ] bother
me taking pictures yes it is kind of
annoying
especially after you perform
you just want to eat and chill
that's it and hang out with a girlfriend
it's not going to work so i just go to
the hotel room yeah i have a joint i
have some hot chocolate in the lobby
hot chocolate in the lobby [ __ ] yeah so
sugar free from that [ __ ] little
german family
i do it right though i do it right i
ain't got time for [ __ ] [ __ ] games
from that little german family what else
has been going on with you you've been
touring touring yeah so you're going to
new york next week i'm going to be in
new york i'll be in bananas all right no
but you just doing sets around this i'm
doing i'm taping comedy knockout
this week and then i'm taping a new show
next week okay and then i have bananas
on april 7th and you'll be in new york
for how long two weeks nice time of the
year it's a great time to be in new york
um staying up in harlem for the first
couple days and then probably down in
chelsea area i like to be central so i
can get everywhere everywhere all my old
spots me i don't like to move around
while i'm in new york i not yeah i grew
up there i seen all the spots i go to
jimmy and norton whatever jimmy's show
with the dude right outside they got
gyros they got cyber hot dogs they got
the dude right there they got the deli
down the corner i hop back in that hoop
i take it right back to the ferry and
you go across over the river
[ __ ] uh weehawken i take an uber to
the hotel and then you stay in jersey
yeah your stomping grounds yeah i want
there's a cuban restaurant down the
corner that delivers i don't make no
misunderstanding yeah i roll around a
bit and if i go up that hill like last
week i stayed in nyack and it was great
i got great food delivered to the
hotel it was a great one i love that i
love that levity club you like it too i
loved it i fell in love staff everything
everybody it's the seller tremendous
food was good food is good the food is
good that good it was great i love that
that's my new [ __ ] favorite joke
that's a great club i first looked at
the ceilings i'm like [ __ ] the ceilings
are hot yeah and you're worried about
the sound and like how it's going to
travel it's a beautiful thing you've got
it set up good saturday night i told you
some kid got hit in the head with a
bottle he told me that yes [ __ ]
tremendous tremendous he said it was the
best night of his life last night he got
hit in the head was his birthday best
night of his [ __ ] life and that's the
second you know they're savages let me
tell you what happened saturday night
that really doesn't happen a lot
but when it happens it throws you off
like it hurts my feelings when it
happens yeah okay
every show is great saturday night final
show you gotta get hyped you gotta get
this is the first one that sells out
yeah these [ __ ] been waiting
for you they drove six hours
i go up there everything's rocking and
rolling but at about the 18 minute mark
there's a guy
that's just talking
and just talking like in the first show
there was a girl when the check came she
giggled that [ __ ] i could deal with yeah
okay and i don't usually say anything
bad
this guy kept going i mean
after i'd say every joke where's lee
he was talking to you yeah like like and
he was being annoying people were
looking at me and i'm listening to this
guy and finally at the 42 minute mark he
started the 18 minute mark yeah and he
just went and you didn't do nothing
listen if you give them attention
because then you got to do it you got to
get into it i just i just stopped and i
go do me a favor bro stop it
and i went to say a joke and he talked
again
i said dog please and he i said they're
going to go listen
the next time i gotta ask you to [ __ ]
leave
and the room got silent and that's it
you just lost the battle you yeah you
just lost the battle yes but for some
reason i go hey none of you guys got my
back and now they all went bananas yeah
and the guy sat there glaring at me all
[ __ ] pissed off all night
embarrassing his wife
embarrassing the couple he came with and
i understand you listen to the podcast
but that gives you no right to act that
way right because this isn't the podcast
it's like me going to your [ __ ] job
and hitting you with a needle one one
time at the top of every minute and the
most important part where you were
trying to like a game of operation i
would say a punchline and he'd be like
asking a stupid question oh you're gonna
smoke briefly right joey you're gonna
are you gonna hang out joey are you
gonna what the [ __ ]
well get a baby you know like i finally
answered one time i go no i got a 5 45
flight i got to get the [ __ ] out of here
he's like we'll get a baby said i go
listen that's what the brown with
americans everybody got a babysitter and
when the kid shows up with milo
yiannopoulos at your door
you wonder what happened where did my
parenting skills go wrong well you know
you got a babysitter yeah babysitter
sucked his dick and he liked it yep so
now what the [ __ ] you gonna do and the
guy's name was chuck so shock the [ __ ]
chuck the [ __ ] well
so i don't know if the guy liked that he
kept making little [ __ ] remarks like
he was like ed mcmahon but it was i
don't mind getting heckled this guy
wasn't heckling see that's the thing
like it was a big interrupting it was a
little it's like when you try to fall
asleep and somebody leaves the radio on
yes
that's the best way to describe it yep
and it's not loud at all but you hear
all the commercials yes do you slip in
your tub
you know call one eight hundred don't
slip no more social security packages
are discovered you know what i'm saying
two three hundred empires yeah you can
hear that as a soft
like i don't mind that night i like the
sound of a fan
i like when i go to a hotel and i put it
on high and i hear the fans yeah but
that's different than like actual
conversation and that it was just a
little chatter and it was just stupid
questions
but the fact that it was to you is
brazen you know what i mean like some
people are just talking and being
interruptive to each other but when he's
talking to you that's crazy it was crazy
that's crazy
every once in a while you have those
type of shows i
when i was a feature act i used to go
off for no reason and there's still a
tape of me going off
opening up for roger in ontario maybe 12
years ago yeah that people hated me for
because the guy
there's times that there's a performer
on stage at that time joe rogan was on
fear factor
and let me tell you what used to happen
oh god i can't even imagine we're going
back 2000 joe rogan was on fear factor
he was a very good looking guy
so
what happens
you've been in relationships before
that's very presumptuous when you go to
your boyfriend and go hey honey
i want to go see uh
ryan reynolds naked no i want to go see
uh john stamos [ __ ] a goat no no i
want to go see somebody you know like
when remember for a while these [ __ ]
good looking guys got into bands and
[ __ ] like that yeah like good looking uh
let's say like i'm just throwing this
out yeah yeah like gavin rise there so
you come to me right i'm 26 i lift
weights i do steroids you know i love
you you know i love you my mother's
gonna love you okay and one day at
dinner you go guess what i got us
tickets to go see john bon jovi
so i like mon joey i love bon jovi since
day one but now in my demented
self-esteem low self-esteem mind i
popped a question
do you like bon jovi no i don't like bon
jovi
so all of a sudden my demented head
you're even dealing with somebody that
jealous i was that jealous so i know
exactly i know how this works
when you're that type of jealous and all
of a sudden now even though i like bon
jovi i [ __ ] love bonjour bon jovi's
[ __ ] hate bon jovi bon jovi's a puke
okay [ __ ] bon jovi last week we were
listening to say goodbye when i was
sucking a dick in the car now you don't
like bon jovi all of a sudden yeah this
guy came to a joe rogan show hating joe
rog
sitting with a mug because his wife was
like yes jaroke yep in love so i go up
i'm just a shitty fat [ __ ]
you know and i'm trying to be cute it's
joe rogan's show yep it's fear factor
i'm not gonna go up there and be witty
i'm not gonna win them over i'm just
killing [ __ ] time and practice and
new material right
this guy just started heckling
he started hacking
[ __ ] you and joe rogan man [ __ ] you and
joe rogan the poor girl was turning pink
this poor girl from the aids he gave her
no from the [ __ ] embarrassment yeah
from the [ __ ] embarrassment because
this guy is just so he's such an
insecure you're twice and i've been
there
everyone has you know what it's like
when your girlfriend says i'm going to
see the partridge family you like
[ __ ] departure family you like
[ __ ] donny osmond you want to in the
sixth grade i was in love with a girl
she liked donnie osmond every time she
put the osmonds on i'd cry in the corner
like a [ __ ] and throw a fit what are
your chances of meeting donnie osmond
you're a fat [ __ ] chick in new jersey
you know what i'm saying what was i
thinking you know she wasn't a fat
[ __ ] thing she was hot
but at that age
in my [ __ ] world every time i heard
the [ __ ] i love the osmonds i love the
osmosis one bad apple don't spoil the
whole chicken with you i don't care what
they say
i don't care what you heard that one bad
it was dumb against the jacksons jack
it was it was the osmosis against the
jacksons for a while wasn't it really
yes for what like where were they like
it was the jackson's put on abc
bro
johnny yeah
put the video on put on abc
and i'm back put on one bad apple
from donny and marie osmond yeah watch
what the [ __ ] do you think they became
famous because she's a fat [ __ ] and got
a talk show in the daytime they were
famous when you were an itch in your
daddy's pants
put on abc by the jackson five okay this
is why it was the [ __ ] jackson's oh
yeah i gotta teach you a whole [ __ ]
generation abc is no joke but listen
listen but i don't know about the donny
osmond i'm gonna [ __ ] i'm gonna give
it to you right now they had beef on the
street just listen to this all right why
talk when you can listen you ever think
of that why talk just put the [ __ ]
thing on watch
watch abc
listen to abc for three
this record has been minutes on do you
not find the [ __ ] song speed that up
a little bit mtv jams
there you go kick it up
this is what
oh [ __ ]
listen for this
[Music]
listen to the voice
[Music]
put on one bad apple
[Music]
by donny osmond
or the osmonds or whatever the [ __ ]
comes up
okay
i gotta give these youngsters in there
you're on 2 000 milligrams of [ __ ]
edible trying to do this [ __ ]
not live one bad
the osmonds but all right that yeah that
one's right there click that one right
there whatever the [ __ ] that was
unbelievable what i gotta deal with
one bad apple he hasn't
voted
oh my god even the outfit hold on the
second one all right put on the first
one yes i could see
listen to the song listen to the [ __ ]
song all right
i'm gonna get i'm gonna schooling you
[ __ ] what was going on
[Music]
yeah you need love but you're afraid
that look at these mormons they were
mormons someone else
the little one is donny right you see
him
this is what you missed
this is what nobody saw
look at that cute [ __ ] what when
that [ __ ] came to town you sucked that
mormon dick remember on that show
on that music show on hbo when they
signed them
remember that music show listen
my head is blown
this is this guy's
terrifying
he won't give me chance
he looks like a human worm
i think i'm still jackson okay i need to
go back to i want you back by the
jackson five get the video of them
knew that you singing
don't know nothing about nothing because
that's what the church and what's
happening now is giving you is giving
you a [ __ ] you ain't gonna learn this
[ __ ] i had no idea there was beef put on
i want your back it was not a beef it's
a beef it was it was not a beef it was
called
right there right there
look at them black people with capes
that's when you know it's gonna look at
this [ __ ]
now watch this
oh my god
are you [ __ ] kidding me yeah this was
america 1970 this is 1969.
they had never seen nothing like this
speed it up a little bit
so you can see the brother jermaine see
that
see the one with that
not yet
not yet
i don't think it compares
watch but watch the style you're going
to see right now
no speed it up a little bit
don't worry about my comparison see the
brother in the back with the blue shirt
yeah right there go go
watch here we go
okay
see yeah patterned the same thing yeah
watch and watch
see
the other brother would sing
that's the one that left the jackson
five
married barry gordy
and that's why there was no more jackson
five that guy he left he stayed with
motown and the jacksons left motown
as a family and [ __ ] jermaine stayed
and married barry gordy's daughter oh
[ __ ] and he put out a soul um which was
a disaster and the jacksons became the
jacksons and what they did was they had
another younger brother who played the
bongos yeah and they put him in the band
and that's the that's how the jackson
became but i have a question go ahead
now the osmonds what time do they come
around they came around right there they
were neck and neck so a little while but
then michael jackson over i mean
obviously but donnie's i didn't know i
did a voice like that dog but once he
turned it changed her team the game
changed his voice changed so america
gave them a a tv variety show did you
know yeah i remember that show
every friday night yeah i mean i don't
remember it but i know this girl's house
and just sit there
well she watched donny osmond with her
grandmother and mother and [ __ ] brother
they would watch the [ __ ] osmonds he
wasn't gay i mean he was just a [ __ ]
nerd too
because you know i wasn't into the
osmonds i'm not gonna sit here and watch
these [ __ ] mopes
but these people were cuban they
embarrassed me you know what i'm saying
but at that time i wasn't [ __ ] i was
just dry humping it
you're only dry humping that's it can't
come that's it paint come and we just
sit there and look at each other and
make believe that i just said pants
um
we just said we put on earth wouldn't
fire and you in your pants would catch
on fire i dry hump on the death to the
whole album of uh that's in the way of
the world
[ __ ] you
i used to bust a zipper every day you
know what i'm saying
never did i see one time i saw her
titties and all those years
and i never even went for her monkey i
was so confident
i was very satisfied just dry hump and i
get a little dizzy oh my god
that was it that my stepfather caught
her in the closet one time and that was
the end of that too
in your like legit closet or like yeah
my clown almost homosexual closet yeah
my closet my stepdad came home my
stepdad no he opened up the thing she
was sitting that topless
he's like tyler put his shirt on then
both of you can get the [ __ ] out how old
are you
maybe 12. oh that's so cute
that's so cute pant coming at 12. she
broke
my [ __ ] soul of course she did she
didn't break my heart she broke my soul
yeah that broke me for three or four
years
until you were 15. it was no like she
broke me at 12.
broke me like i got my back like it was
[ __ ] up i couldn't go to summer school
i couldn't think all out i stopped going
to karate i stopped playing it was your
first pant come situation it was my
first love it was just i was just brutal
and we got caught playing hooky we would
play hooky every day after for the
second session
we would go to school from 9 to twelve
and then go to shop right we would steal
hubba bubba
and then go
and confess our love to one another oh
my god we were gonna run away
like we're gonna bust out like bon jovi
that's why that album always reminds me
because everybody from new jersey will
bust out together what was her name new
yorker
new yorker new yorker she was cuban
n-u-i-r-k-a
nuka nuka and she was gorgeous oh my god
bang
yeah
and it's [ __ ] crazy we dated flowers
and i was in love with it and my mother
[ __ ]
called her mother a [ __ ] and
called her a [ __ ] in spanish and that
was the end of the dry hump other than
[ __ ] i couldn't no more can't come after
you call them tough
but then
two years later
we were friends
we were [ __ ] you know friends you
guys would go for coffee no no there was
no coffee in those days we rolled up
bicycles and played youtube
and [ __ ] got the idea oh look who
woke up and just said you who i hated
her [ __ ] brother i [ __ ] hated him
and he hated me but we all hung out with
the same clan so he could never really
do nothing to me
and one day i had this bicycle my friend
valentin used to steal bicycles and redo
them
and he used to go take this bicycle take
it for a ride let me know what you think
and i would come back and go it's not a
bad bicycle you gotta fix the [ __ ]
tire pressure you gotta put a ball on
the chain
and you go okay whatever
so one day i take a bicycle from him i
go uh he goes take this bicycle let me
know how it feels when you shift
and as i was going down there like a
valentine the the stream wheel's not
right and he goes don't worry
just just you you're only going to go to
charles courtney back i got it right i'm
going to go to charles court so i go to
charles court which is the street over
charles court is a circular street yeah
we call this a cult of sacrifice yeah it
didn't close off but you could just make
a circle in the middle it was a an
island
sword and there was two houses that were
back to back to each other
so we were i dropped a bicycle on the
bottom of the at like on the middle of
the island
and
we were playing stickball like over here
by by dean lapreet's house and the
sabbatino and this kid named john prange
well i just did an interview of the
iceman that was the guy at the iceman's
helper he had mr softy truck his kids
were all playing
and new york was there with a bunch of
other girls and we just do you know what
what 12 year olds do yeah you know in
new jersey we play stickball and other
girls were playing nobody was into [ __ ]
then we were just we were just starting
to like [ __ ] and whatever
and she picked up the 10 speed
right now i'm over here playing
stickball and i see her pick up the 10
speed
and i do a new yorker be careful with
the [ __ ] steering wheel so she grabs
onto the steering wheel and she comes up
the hill
and she's pedaling up towards me i never
forget she's pedaling up top
or she took the bike from like a corner
and she went by me yeah
so we went
the other way of the island to catch
catcher i kept saying new york i watched
the [ __ ]
me and like three of my buddies like new
yorker watched the steering wheel you
know when somebody steals your bicycle
yeah goof on you she did it as one of
that oh she didn't know it was funny she
didn't know it was [ __ ] so she gets on
and she's she also she takes the turn
and she's going downhill we're coming
from this way like this and i'm yelling
at new york to stop the bicycle new york
has stopped the bicycle new york can
stop the bicycle the [ __ ] steering
wheel and she's giggling the whole way
[ __ ] and we're like new york has stopped
the bicycle and she went to turn away
from us oh god and she went over the
[ __ ] steering wheel right bam banged
up
she got up you know
we carried her up she was fine
we talked to her for a while i was just
really stressed out oh my god i grabbed
that story really stressed me out oh you
have no [ __ ] idea
i thought she i pictured her careening
over a cliff we all said our goodbyes
and went home at seven o'clock to eat
dinner at our own homes
the next day i go to school eight number
one the teachers are waiting for me
outside there did you hear the news
new yorker had a blood clot in her brain
they're in intensive care she might not
make the day
from her falling on the bike so i lived
with that till this day
i did not push her off the bike i did
not go for she didn't hear us and when
she went to turn away from us
she went over the front handlebars
i mean it was bad it was like she was
telling the mother open up the windows
my grandfather wants me open up the
windows she was saying that yeah they
were crying in the room and [ __ ] i can
see my grandpa he wants me to come with
him she said she could see her
grandfather
oh my god so at the end of the school
day we all went over to the house and
then you know they got out of intensive
care
she's gonna be in a coma for a while but
she's gonna make it induced coma like i
don't know i don't [ __ ] remember it
was like this [ __ ] i was in the
eighth grade
i was in the
eighth grade and she was a freshman
okay because i got left back yeah
so
i went over there every day and bought a
goldfish she like goldfish after they
shaved the head
oh my god let me tell you how good
looking this [ __ ] was
with a shaved head in 1970 [ __ ] 70.
just rocking it she still won the
homecoming yeah queen freshman i'm sure
she was she was just
gorgeous i had gone crazy like i was out
of my league
she didn't even tell me i can't kiss you
in front of the other people we used to
just walk home together and go behind
the wall and make out and i'd dry hump
her up against the wall
so we never dated again you know
did she recover she recovered and then
that was when i was in the eighth grade
and she was a freshman and i'd see her
at the high school and i'd say hello and
we were still kind of friendly and
and one day my mom dies
i think she comes to the wake
and then like a year or two later i'm
living at the bender's house and i'm a
junior in high school
and one sunday night mr bend i hear the
doorbell ring mr bender goes there's a
girl out there she wants to talk to you
i go outside it's nikki ariza shut up
[ __ ] she's a 12 now yeah you know
like i never at that point i was into
other girls the heartbreak was done of
course i would see her and not really
look at it and i go what's going on
and i looked at the tits and they were
ginormous she hit the side of the head
that controls the growth of your tits
so her tits in high school senior year
were mountains and it also she hit the
side of her head that controls this is
the crazy can someone punch me in that
on my way out but she also [ __ ] her up
because she was as catholic as i was
obviously that's why we were dry
right i mean the day she i sucked the
titties she cried for four days
and those days that was the last thing
on your mind
that you were gonna suck your tits when
you were so into catholic
but let me tell you something bro she
looked me straight in the face
and it was like three weeks away from
the senior prom
and she goes coco i need a big favor
from you
and she like we never had sex and she
looked me straight in the fish she was
only a big favor for me she goes i don't
have a date for the senior prom
she got me and my boyfriend broke up and
i'm not in the mood of getting a
boyfriend
she goes if you take me to the senior
prom
i will make it worth your while i will
[ __ ] your [ __ ] bro i mean
she went from a girl that didn't even
talk that way
to like knowing how to talk that way
like i will [ __ ] your [ __ ] brains out
you will [ __ ] come to death
and it was so intimidating i was like
i'll call you in a week and i just
slammed the door i went in i jerked off
like the fear went away and i never
called her again you never did [ __ ] no
that's how prudish i was at that time
like she's scared it could also [ __ ] out
of me but you know when people say they
don't want to meet their idols or their
heroes because they're going to be
disappointed it could have been bad
maybe it was better you didn't no if
anybody was going to be bad
if funny was going to be bad lacking in
the sex the problem was going to be me
at that time
i would just get excited and come all
over myself and run home you never
called her again now is she petrified
joe you gave her a [ __ ] brain
interest and the least you could have
done was fisted the girl seven years ago
i was talking to a friend of mine she
goes guess who i saw and i go home and
she was naked like how's she doing and
she goes she definitely doesn't want to
talk to you
i go really listen she goes coco i was
there that day
you didn't do anything wrong you went
you were yelling at her she was giggling
she didn't hear you guys
and she went over the steering wheel she
goes i was there i knew how you felt i
know how you reacted
i always felt bad about it but i tried
to friend her on facebook
she pretty much told me to go [ __ ]
myself i actually sent her a message and
i heard you bump into my friend lisa
you know i constantly think of you you
know i know her mom had died and i sent
the note you know
but whatever people will uh look at
things i mean they hang on to things and
from a certain way over the years she
just went off yeah
a lot of beautiful girls tend to she
went off the deep end so i always lived
with that that
jesus [ __ ] christ like it wasn't your
fault
you know you couldn't it's one of those
life moments where people make a choice
and it puts them on a path and you could
have you know a leaf could have fallen a
different way and something else would
have happened differently it's just that
those little you know life's
trajectories is very they're very
complicated and where they end up is out
of our hands it's amazing the [ __ ] that
happens to us as we grow up in the
relationships we have when you yeah it's
crazy and you think back to them there's
a girl on facebook that i'm dying to say
something
you should do it if you feel it in your
gut you should why can't what's the
worst is going gonna happen if you my
thing is if you have something like that
where there's an emotion behind the
desire
you should do it she told me your mother
died
i went over the house to give her a
stabbing
when we were like in eighth grade we
played cyo basketball and she played she
was a cheerleader you sound like a ghost
sounds like you're haunting the podcast
she was she was a cheerleader at the
holy rosary
she went to holy rosary academy and i
went to saint michaels i played for
saint michael so automatically that made
them cheerleaders and she was a cute
little redhead with freckles irish chick
the ones i liked oh they're they're
rabbits i love that those [ __ ]
they're wild again you know you're just
dry humping me we were 13. you're
looking earlobes i know we've been like
holding hands and going to movies that's
cute i was doing it too i was cute we'd
meet on wednesdays and get a slice of
pizza yeah we sit and do our homework
together go to the playground swing on
the swing set
she didn't have that devious mind and i
didn't have it and then one night at
that early age we started talking on the
phone about it
and we just said okay maybe tomorrow
i'll come by your mother's buy your
house and she goes okay
it snowed and we had a snow day and then
i went like an hour for the bus to go
down and i was all excited i walk in
there and we're bullshitting and almost
like we're gonna ask you a question what
does your father get home
she goes my father gets home like about
five i know what time is your money come
she goes i don't have a mother my mother
died
my dick went into my nutsack not only
did i not want to drive but i had never
oh that just got me hard actually i've
never heard death gets me hard like at
that age i had never heard nobody's
mother died right being that young when
you need your mom yeah you're like why
you do yeah
for your mother yeah you must have done
something terrible like a week later we
actually had sex you did and then i
dumped them for this girl mcneil oh
i couldn't take that you know you know
how you feel about the handlebars this
girl probably has no idea she's probably
thinking about this is a girl you want a
message
you got a message this is horrible you
need you should put her on the podcast
oh you don't know what he wants to say
to her yeah no no no no no no no no you
ready yeah
oh god when i wake up at three in the
morning at night and go downstairs and
find my mother dead on the floor yeah
what do you think the first thing that
popped in my mind was
her colleen
i didn't forget like how i treated her i
looked her up on facebook she's on
facebook it's taken me about a year to
even message you
you still haven't no i don't have the
heart to i don't know what made me do
that at that age i still feel guilty
about something
you know but everyone like that
i had a kid call me kev kevin hart was
somebody i was in love with black kevin
hart white kevin hart acted black like
all the white guys i grew up with no
where did you grow up syracuse new york
okay yeah how old do you know i'm 34.
you're a young girl yeah so well how
will be the first time you had sex 16.
and was it for somebody you were in love
with uh no it was it was against my will
really yeah okay that's not bad either
yeah you know now as an adult you know
it's kind of fun but as a teenager it's
not the most fun when was the first time
you had sex with somebody you loved in
high school you were a cheerleader he
was a [ __ ] organ player you know i
didn't probably not until i was like 19.
it took a while to kind of figure all
that [ __ ] out get off did you was it a
tough heartbreak yeah the first one oh
yeah is it tough for women also like i
think well the problem with women is
like after we
have sex usually we just if we like you
then we want to be with you all the time
you know it's like that bonding chemical
that is released into us because nature
wants us to be with you so we can rear a
child and have a baby and do what we're
you know genetically meant to do it's
very difficult for women to break away
from that so i think you know if you if
you sleep with a guy if you [ __ ] him
you're just like okay well i guess i'm
this is it we need to build a hut and
have children and i should you know grow
wheat and he can go out and hunt that's
like what's in our mind
that's when you were 19 do you ever
think of where is he i talked to him
still okay yeah you're friends really
good friends yeah he was the first guy
probably one of the only guys i dated
that treated me the way i deserved to be
treated why did you guys break up i
moved to new york to pursue comedy yeah
yeah we try to stay in touch you know we
try to make that work but i i just fell
in love with comedy it was the first
that was my second love i guess you know
and i just devoted myself to that
and he tried to you know come visit me
but you know how you're on the grind
you're just what do i tell this girl on
facebook i think this is 1977
that song pegged by by by uh steely damn
still makes you think of her her
sister's name was peg yeah and her and
her sister will [ __ ] knock out why
don't you send her the link of the video
i can't do that yes you can no because
that meant i love the sister that the
only reason why i think of it
when i hear packages because that was
awesome she might make her laugh
no she's married now like i went on
facebook and checked her out she's
married she has an autistic kid oh
i think you need to send her something
you think yeah i do because
who cares you know it probably would it
would like it was a complete douchey
[ __ ] move watch me say this and then
she just sends a burning bag of [ __ ] to
one of your comedy shows like like ten
days after that whole thing went down i
went down there with dean
and i think i'd
we we messed around in like an alleyway
like i busted her up in an alleyway
like and then i [ __ ]
walked to home she cried a little bit i
called her the next day
and then i went to a party and i hooked
up with this girl
and i called her and i was like i can't
uh
i i told her i was going to basketball
camp and i wouldn't see her all summer
so you at least you said something to
her you had it so it's not that bad
you're riddled with guilt about [ __ ] i
think you're riddled with guilt and it's
much worse than you think she got a hot
cuban girlfriend hot banging that was
also 13 and she was dating silvio this
basketball oh that [ __ ] silvio
not sylvia later i saw janeiro's in
hoboken new jersey yep at this like
bebop joint where average you know like
how are you doing with the gold chain oh
yeah
and she was standing in front of us this
chili the cuban girl
and i was with a bunny in my of mine
fernie basisudo and these other dudes
pelican and stinky
stinky and we're watching i hate to know
why he got that name with watching a
band and there's a girl here and there's
a cuban girl is here now this is the
girl that was on the cheerleading squad
with us in the 8th grade now we're 18
19. yeah i haven't seen him in years but
my buddy fernie stands right here and i
used to always play with her like we
used to always double date yeah so she
was cuban so i talked to her in cuba and
giggle
and i saw and i looked over at that and
i looked at my friend fern he was half
[ __ ] was it was but he had glasses
big good looking guy and i just pinched
her ass but she didn't she didn't turn
this way she turned that way and he was
drinking an alabama slam i'll never
forget this and she just punched him
right in the face and he had a white
shirt on his glasses the lens fell out
and he couldn't see he was like going
for his glasses and she's teeing off on
him kicking him outside it's terrible he
too will not talk to me on facebook
really
oh you need to bring up these memories i
think i [ __ ] hit him up about a year
ago and i said there's not a week that
goes by and i don't think of you
and he said you me as you
and i hit him back like a month later
and i go hey uh
i'm coming to new york if you ever want
to do lunch let me know i'm coming to
the city nothing but saturday night
some friends of mine came and one of the
guys go you ever talk to fernie anymore
like a dog he won't return my medicals
he went bro i knew fernie says we were
[ __ ] six and i saw him in the city
and say hello
and he shook my hand and gave me a hug
and he said he couldn't talk to me
anymore he walked away i go yeah for
anyone off the deep end so you went off
the deep end too
yeah
why are all your friends going off the
deep end because we grew up at the late
70s in the areas
of cocaine yeah and it took their minds
as adolescents like it took mine yeah
they took mine but it took them a little
deeper [ __ ] man it took them a little
bit you know how you see weed stores
popping up yeah
that's how i saw cocaine popping up
everywhere it was it was everywhere you
get it everywhere like one minute one
person had it the next minute i would go
to your uncle's house and he goes come
here you know anybody who couldn't get
rid of cocaine i got an ounce and a half
in the house like i've never i've never
done cocaine god bless you ever and
you're doing the right thing you smoke
grief i smoke weed you eat some weed
pretzels from time to time yeah i know i
love that [ __ ] a little bit of tequila
here and there sometimes you know little
bailey's in the coffee if i feel like it
so this uh
oh got you going off the deep end gently
call it the weed store dispenser
dispenser you're opening will it be open
seven days a week
yeah i think we're doing seven days a
week what's the ordinance now how long
can you stay open late to eight o'clock
it's eight o'clock yeah they had places
up here that were staying up until two
no more yeah no you see there we see
they were selling wheat on the streets
then nobody gave a [ __ ] especially the
legalization they're going to have a lot
more regulations are you under all those
rules with the regulations we're going
legit
yeah you have to have a campaign yeah at
all times and you have to be responsible
yeah every seed
it's tough yeah travis and i are
crossing the t's and dotting the eyes
because we see what's going on he's out
there going to town hall meetings taking
notes
and just making sure
we're good for 4 20. do you have a show
anyway yeah i'm going to be in columbus
ohio
at the funny bone no [ __ ] yeah yeah
damn it friday saturday just the 420
show oh that's it that's it just one
special show yeah that's a good show
today at 4 20. that's a great place to
do a 420 can i can we smoke weed in ohio
i've [ __ ] done everything in ohio i
know it's like but the last couple years
there was a debt squad crew that was
going to watch the shows
and the one guy one day showed up with a
[ __ ] brown bag of
you know
they were trying to do the edibles we
were talking about yeah like the gelatin
would melt you know on the way over and
stuff they had a lot of heart but i got
good weed in columbus that's listen
but is it legal there i have no phone i
don't think it's legal in ohio which
makes it more fun yeah so come out to
the show see i was supposed to
originally be at the stress factor yeah
but a bunch of shows got switched over
and i had to do a movie so it would have
been easier for me if i would have just
switched over so i did 420 and oxnard
i'll shoot them you're doing 420 and
oxnard that's great just shoot right
down there yeah so i'll shoot at the
levity
yeah monday tuesday wednesday shooting
and friday thursday if not i would have
had to cancel thursday in new york
i would have had a cancer 20th so i said
you can't do that yeah i'll cancel the
whole week and reschedule shoot the
movie do the [ __ ] weekend in oxnard
and
i'm in california yeah you're good you
know the stars that that they're going
to come
the company's going to come yeah
they're going to give me a bag to
[ __ ] throw out oh my god that's gonna
be crazy everybody the holy eucharist
you know what i'm saying that's the holy
eucharist there's a star of death
ali how are you feeling over there
you're hearing his eyes are still closed
his face is still red from the bong he
did two hours ago there was a moment
there where he just was making noises
out of it let me wrap this up here i'm
happy you came on tonight thank you for
having me
i miss you what's the name of the
dispensary it's gonna be called the
flora organica and i'm 37th and broadway
47th and broadway and then i have in
just my showtime podcast listen between
us when you first told me uh where the
[ __ ] it was
south central yeah do i have to wear a
bulletproof vest but i forget that
gentrifying no it's
it's we're in we're the main
we're in a thoroughfare it's dope
literally and figuratively so you'll be
over there i'll be at levity live on the
20th in oxnard but i'll also be on the
27th i'll be at the temblo bruin house
and bakersfield [ __ ] great show
that's a great room yeah i love it you
got that's a wonderful show it's a
wonderful wonderful show don't forget to
come out to that let me talk to you
about real [ __ ] quick correct
listen everybody talks about sex and
loving you got to elevate your underwear
game to the next level with me undies
you perfected your wardrobe but what
about the stuff not everybody gets to
see
what is me on these it's the most
seriously soft feel good undies
delivered right to your door
me undies are designed in la and made
from substantially sourced micro moldol
a fabric three times softer than cotton
me undies softer than cotton luxury
underwear has come in every changing
selection of classic colors bold shades
and adventurous patterns so you can
tailor your undies to your own personal
smile style and guess what you can save
time and money each month with a monthly
subscription that's right and if you're
not ready for a subscription that's okay
too you can still save as a member of
the church i'm gonna i'm gonna offer you
20 off your first pair
just use our special url meundies.com
joey and get 20 off your first pair so
go ahead buddy revamp your underwear
game you can't have skid marks and
[ __ ] burn marks what were your
penises that scares women you gotta
revamp it you gotta look sharp and they
gotta be sharp once again meundies.com
joey
meundies.com
joey i'm gonna give you 20 off today all
right
also
real quick here
i want to talk about a service that's
blowing up here i like them i don't use
them because i can i don't need to hire
somebody but a friend of mine emailed me
and said it worked out for him are you
hiring do you know where to post your
job to find the best candidates no you
don't posting your job in one place
isn't enough
to find quality good candidates if you
want to find the perfect hire you need
to post your job on all the top job
sites and now you can with
ziprecruiter.com
you can post your job to 200 plus job
sites including social media networks
like facebook and twitter with a single
click first candidates in any city
industry
nationwide find candidates in any city
or industry nationwide just post once
and watch your qualified candidates roll
into zip recruiters easy to use
interface no juggling emails no calls to
your office no crazy people showing up
quickly screen candidates rate them and
hire the right person quickly find out
today why zip recruiter has been used by
fortune 100 companies and thousands of
small and medium-sized businesses and
right now my listeners can post jobs on
ziprecruiter for free by going to
ziprecruiter.com
slash church again ziprecruiter.com
slash church
give it for free go at ziprecruiter.com
take a chance columbus did you want the
best that's out there you got to run
with ziprecruiter.com i want to thank
me undies and i want to thank helix and
i want to thank most of all jessame
paluso
for making me i'm gonna go home and
apologize to that girl on facebook you
should thank you you're right i always
felt guilty about it and i couldn't have
this clear your conscience life is too
short to wonder what would have happened
just do it
thank you for having me on coco i love
you man i love you too i appreciate your
congratulations on your guys success
thank you
you know you have security down there
and everything yeah it's security every
day so don't try and [ __ ] with us
that's that's the most important thing
you can't have nobody [ __ ] get it we
got dobermans we got a moat with
alligators i could shoot a [ __ ] dope
man so you're gonna have big ass black
[ __ ]
[ __ ] lee i love you thanks for
coming out i love you guys have a great
weekend thank you for listening i owe it
to you guys stay black lee
don't go to the grand canyon what about
attack chickens though what about yeah
just go back attack chickens yeah you
forgot about your attack put the music
on lee what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
you had one job
[Music]